czy urzędujący poseł
powinien startować w wyborach do europarlamentu
tak oczywiście każdy może i zazwyczaj tak jest
że startują właśnie ci
którzy już mają jakieś doświadczenie
zazwyczaj parlamentarne jest pewien szczebel
ja swoją karierę zaczynałem OD radioosiedla
później byłem radnym
widzę prezydentem miasta
dopiero później startowałem na posła
teraz dostałem taką szansę startować na
do parlamentu europejskiego
a ponieważ te wybory do parlamentu europejskiego
traktujemy jako policja obywatelska
bardzo poważnie
bo ta kadencja przyszła
będzie
bardzo ważna z uwagi na bezpieczeństwo również polski
to zdecydowałem się yy kandydować
polityka jest grą zespołową i jeżeli ym
trudno to rozdzielić
żeby Po prostu poseł o tym decydował czy kandyduje
czy i zostaje na tym w tym miejscu gdzie jest
no to tak być też nie powinno
jeżeli ym ym
informacja polityczna z której się wywodzi uznaje
że powinien mieć
yy przydzielone zadania w innym zakresie
powinien się z tego też wy yy wywiązać
pamiętać trzeba o 1 rzeczy
wydaje mi się najbardziej tutaj
w tym wszystkim podstawowej
to jest taka
że na końcu i bardzo dobrze decydują o tym wyborcy
decydują o tym polacy
jeśli ma taką możliwość
Jak najbardziej
bo sprawy które są
procedowane na płaszczyźnie parlamentu krajowego
mają swój początek
najczęściej na płaszczyźnie parlamentu europejskiego
Sami wiecie państwo
Jak często dochodzi do ratyfikacji przepisów unijnych
to dotyczy wszystkich sfer życia
więc to jest niezwykle ważne
aby yy była ta łączność
aby było to doświadczenie
nie widzę powodów
żeby nie mógł startować
bo startuje na również na stanowisko posła
poseł startuje
na posła tylko że do parlamentu europejskiego
to że te kadencje nie są
jakby jednocześnie się nie rozpoczynają
nie kończą powoduje
że
posłowie mogą startować na posła
do parlamentu europejskiego
yy myślę że tak
że może startować do euro parlamentu
chociaż co do zasady uważam
że yy posłowie posłanki senatorowie
senatorzy yy powinni pełnić swój mandat do końca
ale rozumiem też
że to jest form
start jest formą zapytania wyborców
czy godzą się na taką zmianę
krótka piłka zaobserwuj NAS